hello and welcome to the witching hour i
am perry this is haley and we have a
very special guest on today's episode is
that right well i guess we do perry
we've got harvey guillen who plays
guillermo our favorite familiar on fx is
what we do in the shadows with us he's
here to discuss that season two twist
and what to expect from guillermo in
season three so beware there will be
spoilers well season two spoilers and
vampires lots of vampires before we get
into all that though i wanted to let you
know that today's episode is brought to
you by fx's what we do in the shadows
what we do in the shadows is a
mockumentary series following four
vampires who live where else staten
island this season our favorite
bloodsuckers are elevated to a new level
of power they will also meet the
original vampire encounter gargoyles and
play werewolf kickball plus colin
robinson is turning 100 years old happy
birthday colin you can catch up on
seasons one and two right now they're
both streaming on fx on hulu ahead of
season three which premieres thursday
september 2nd on fx and streams the next
day on fx on hulu hello harvey and
welcome to the witching hour how are you
doing today good how are you thanks for
having me
happy to have you here i dig the
background that poster just pops so
perfectly
i know this is like my little corner
where we started doing the after show
last season uh for what we do in the
shadows
before the shadows.com you can see all
the bts stuff and interviews with all
the
creatives and the cast and whatnot we
did it during the pandemic so the fans
could have something to look at after
and before the show
that chair looks pretty incredible too
yeah it's like there's no corners like
set up to be like the set i'm in the set
i'm on set also my living room
[Laughter]
good thing to have on hand for shows
like this so before we get into what we
do in the shadows we kind of want to go
back to the beginning and get to know
you a little bit and one of my go-to
questions for something like that is i'm
always curious what did what did the
dream look like at the beginning for you
what did making it look like and then
how does it compare to what you've
accomplished now
honestly like for me the dream was to to
do one project like if i did one project
the dream would come true
i remember being like six years old and
watching annie and um and falling in
love with singing and dancing and
wanting to be that and i remember
looking at that and looking over my mom
and i was like mom i want to be that i
want to be an orphan
and she looked at me weird
and she was like yes that's loco and i
was like well what's that it's like no
sonars they're actors i was like oh i
want to be an actor and that's how
that whole thing started and for me it
was like if i even got to set like i
didn't even necessarily
wanted to be the person who was starring
in something or wanted to be in i just
wanted to be on set i love the idea of
like moving lights behind and like the
old-fashioned like you know hooray for
hollywood music
you know all of that i just wanted to be
in the crackle and center of it i didn't
know if i was gonna you know necessarily
be uh a comic relief or shakespearean
actor i just knew that i wanted to be in
that world it sounded so exciting and so
many different uh elements went to
making something happen so and that's
what it looked like and then so when i
first got my first part on tv um
i just remember thinking i i made it
it was like a small like guest star on a
show that ashton kutcher was producing
and i just remember thinking i made it
this is it and then you realize oh wait
no you gotta okay you gotta keep going
because you can't just make a living off
of one day guest star on a show
what was the journey from you know that
first moment you saw annie and realize
you wanted to be an actor to booking
that first role what were the steps you
took to get there it was hard you know
it was crazy i mean this business is uh
you know not for the week of heart and
it's not an easy ride i'm sure um i mean
i'm sure the story is out there they're
like it was so easy you know just like i
asked my dad to make a call
but for the most part it's pretty tough
you know to get into and so it was kind
of discouraging because i didn't see
myself on tv i didn't see anyone who
looked like me on tv so i i just uh it
was very discouraging and i i was like
well i want to do this how do i do this
and i remember that i met a fellow
thespian at school
and she said they were doing an improv
class at the local community center for
like 12.50 and i was like that's it
that's our ticket we need to go to this
improv class and we'll be discovered
because we watched all the disney shows
and we thought that's how kids became
stars like you just had to do something
creative and someone was like wait a
minute who's that kid uh and we're like
we just get in that class we're gonna
discover in hollywood here we come and
uh i asked my mom for the money
and i came from a low-income family and
i was just like can i have this you know
totally just like nico no nothing else
enough but we didn't have money for that
and i was like well if i
i want to take this class this is my
dream you know and she's like well
because you can't do it i just said if
you find your own way you can do
whatever you want you know if you find
your own way and i was like fine then
i'll raise the money myself but i'm like
six you know and we're walking home from
school one day and this guy was going to
trash cans and i was like mom what is he
doing it's gross he's like oh vendelo he
sells the cans and i said you make money
from trash
and she said yeah and i was like so i
ran into her closet got a metal wire
wire hanger like one of those long ones
and i unhooked it into like a long
finger like this and i got a food for
less plastic bag and i went through
trash cans and collected bottles and
cans to pay for my first improv class
that's amazing like
that you got that entrepreneur spirit so
young
yeah
yeah so it's always funny when people
say like oh my god i love you in the
show and where did you come from such an
overnight success and i was like
overnight like i was like i've been
working at this for a while you just
don't see the sweat blood and tears you
know you bringing up that environment
where you expect to walk in and be
discovered it immediately brought me
right back to just being a kid and i
think i would like listen to z100 or
something and there was always a
commercial that was like come to this
you know like casting call at the mall
and you'll be discovered and be on the
disney channel
well i went to those my first audition
ever was uh i think it was like robert
powers agency or something at the mall
at the montebello mall or something and
i asked my mom and my dad and uh my mom
of course said no she's like no no no no
no focus on school and blah blah and my
dad saw how defeated i felt because he
knew it was my dream and he was just
like
like go to the car and i'll see you in
five minutes and so he made up a story
and lied to my mom and like i was
waiting in the car and i felt like we
were like robbing a bank because if mom
found out we're just like i was waiting
for him oh my god he's gonna get caught
isn't it he's not rubbing the bank he's
not rubbing the bank and then he finally
gets there he's like okay we're good and
we went to the audition it was a total
scam like the first thing they said was
like oh my god so talented 500 up front
those are for pictures and then if you
know no just like and we didn't have
that money so i'm glad that we didn't
have that money because i would have
fallen down a different path and it was
just but it was nice to have the
experience and nice to have that support
you know uh to take me to the mall
anyways to audition
so clearly getting discovered doesn't
really happen like that or not for most
people at least
but do you remember any specific point
in your career or a person that you met
that that kind of made you feel seen
like this person sees what i can bring
to this industry and that makes me feel
like i'm here and have a foundation in
this industry
yeah i mean it wasn't until later on um
you know i remember
i had a i i thought that that person was
my high school teacher because they've
been on karate kid 2 as flower man
number 3 and they had an imdb credit and
i was like whoa
like they know what's up like whatever
they say is gold
unfortunately it was very toxic and uh
uh
kind of you know a horrible experience
for all of us because well that's the
first time that you ever were pointed
out as uh being too big being queer like
he would point these things out in class
which looking back was like that person
should not be teaching uh but they were
he would literally call out like the
girls like it's like are you getting
weight you can't be big if you're in
hollywood and i was like can you talk to
us like that like this is we're in high
school and but we didn't know the
difference right as a kid you you
believe your elders you believe someone
who is in a position of power which is
very dangerous because you believe
everything they say you know and so they
would say stuff like you know harvey you
should probably focus just on theater i
don't think tv's for you
and you say stuff like that to a child
basically we're all underage
and you start believing that you're like
well what but you say you i was really
you know you know you're really funny
you're a really funny guy it's just
broadway and stuff will be more free not
even that focus on community theater
and it was just like you were thinking
like are you a mentor or you uh
satan
and so it was really discouraging for a
little bit and looking back i talked to
some of the friends from high school and
stuff and i was like can you believe
that person who's like yeah it's like
that person should not be teaching um
thankfully i don't think they're
teaching anymore at that school at least
they didn't teach anywhere but
after that it wasn't until um i saw a
broadway show that i kind of was like
maybe you know i can be you you can do
it you can do it if you just really
focus and you really want to do it and i
remember seeing marissa jarrett winokur
on hairspray and i was just like whoa
she's the lead of a musical uh she's
round she's proud you know i was like
yes yes you can do it you can actually
do it
cut to now marissa's on our show
and i literally expressed that to her
and i was like do you know that you're
like my first brush oh my god are you
serious she's the loveliest and has been
so encouraging in fact she just sent me
this beautiful like paragraph of
encouragement the other day and it was
just like you never know where your
inspiration's gonna come from and you
never know that one day you'll be
working with the people that you idolize
and so anything is possible
that's amazing and do you like
i don't know i i've had similar theater
experiences when i was in theater school
with like the teachers who let's say
maybe are having a bit of a power trip
so like now that you're in a position
to
possibly influence people looking to do
what you do and providing more of a role
model do you find ways to try to pass it
on in a more powerful way
sort of like what you were saying when
you you know you just saw her on stage
but is that's important to you to like
extend that same
you can do this to kids
absolutely i i pride myself in having
you know um before the pandemic there
was cons and now they're coming back
like you know dragon con and comic cons
and all that and i pride myself in and
having you know kids come up you know
teenagers who are crying and they
literally say i never saw myself on
television i was like i used to say that
too
i used to say the same thing you're
saying and now you're going to be here
one day and someone's going to say it to
you and so like passing that baton or
opening the door even if you leave it
ajar behind you for whoever's coming
behind you because growing up all the
things that i was told were the things
that were against me you know you're
you're too you know round brown and
proud and all those were my strikes
against me
you're too big you're too queer you're
too this you're too that and you start
thinking well i'm just trying to be me
like i'm just trying to live my life why
am i hindering what i am why am i trying
to look a certain certain way that you
were when all those things that were my
you know strikes against me were all my
strengths you know they were all my
strengths and i you didn't see them that
way until i show them to you in that way
and try to be like do you think that
this character why couldn't this
character look like me why couldn't he
talk like me why can't he like in people
like you know what
yeah why not yeah why don't we try and
take a chance on him oh i made a career
out of roles that were never written for
me i made a creative like i look at my
resume
and i would say half of those roles were
not written for me i went in for a role
that was written completely different
they'd never had me in mind and i go in
there and i'm like what do you think and
they're like i never thought of it like
that but
should we give it a go and people take a
chance and they realize whoa that's way
better than we imagined it's like
because you're thinking the
old-fashioned way because you're
thinking of what's already been said by
society standards in hollywood and
you're thinking of filling the mold when
you should be thinking outside the box
that's why things grab your attention or
so unique that people love are the
things that are different
you know the same over and over is
boring so think outside the box
all right jumping into some credits here
you already mentioned that when you
first started out you booked a whole
bunch of small roles on tv shows and
obviously ultimately you went on to have
significant roles on many popular tv
shows but when it comes to those early
ones the really quick stints where you
pop onto a set maybe just for an episode
and that's it which one made the biggest
impression on you where you find
yourself even on a show like what we do
calling back to the lessons learned way
back then
i mean i would have to say one of the
examples of that uh would be one of the
thundermans on nickelodeon where it was
a one-day guest star with two lines
and uh i had just gotten off doing the
internship uh which was also a role that
wasn't in this in the movie i auditioned
for a different role in the movie an
audition for sean levy the director
and he basically was on the floor
laughing and i always say if i don't get
the part my goal is to get the part but
if i don't get it i want to win the room
and if i win the room they'll never
forget you and they'll always think god
i feel like we should and sure enough if
i did my job as an actor i went in there
to give my best even though i wasn't
right for the part it was in the
description for me in that part and i
left to go through another movie
and two weeks later we got a call that
sean had written a part in the movie for
me
and i was like great and i was just like
that's fun so he wrote a whole part just
for me from that audition it was a
two-lane part but i had to go to mo i
moved to atlanta for two and a half
months to film the internship because he
was he was in the scene with all the
villain team like he was part of the
villain but he was the only nice guy in
the villain team and so they made this
really great character and he had to be
there for the whole time and he gets his
you know max manhala gets his
comeuppance at the end of the movie
where i punch him that's like the whole
thing was from one audition that was not
right for me and the next audition after
that was a two line and my uh agent's
like oh you're above that like don't go
in for that if you don't we'll pass
right this audition and i was like well
tell me about the character you know i
used to collect trash to even get to
this place so like tell me about this
character and they're like well he's a
family he's a superhero and i was like i
never played a superhero in my life
because i've never given the chance uh
and i look good and tight so i don't
know what they're talking about but like
it's like the second thing he's a family
member and i was like family and he's
like yeah
well family never goes away family's
always around
even though it's a one-day guest star
for two out of two lines family never
goes away and they're like it's up to
you we say we say pass but if you want
to do it we'll just follow your lead and
i'll say i think i'll audition for it i
audition i get it i get to set i do my
two lines and i improvise a little bit
and the creators are like jed uh he's
like that's funny let's add that and
then he's always that's also funny let's
let's also about that so his two lines
become more and more
three weeks later they write a whole
episode for him for the cousin and then
i recur on that show for four seasons
from one day
these stories are such a testament to
exactly what you were saying which is
that your strength is being yourself and
not trying to hide it like you built
absolutely
that's amazing
it's true it's been true it took me a
while to realize that though because you
know you get cl you know it gets cloudy
and the waters get murky because you're
hearing things and people are it's like
you lose weight you gotta give a block
but don't worry about your hair can't
look like that you can be too feminine
you can't and it's like and you start
just realizing if you just get rid of
all those voices and know what your
focus is and what you're looking at the
end of the tunnel no one's gonna take
that like away from you it's your road
like you build it yourself so stop
looking at intersections and detours and
keep your eye on the end of the tunnel
i'm gonna replay this interview every
time i wake up in a blue mood and you're
going to motivate me
i do want to ask about the what we do
casting process because i love talking
about casting directors and allison
jones is one of the best but before we
skip ahead to that
i have to ask you haley knows this is
coming zoe's extraordinary playlist i am
full-blown obsessed with that show
i
think it is wonderful and it ha it has
had a big impact on my life in the last
two years i love your role on that too
and
that your ending in that role is
something that i won't ever be able to
shake and i'm pretty sure you got one of
the best possible songs for that moment
but it does make me wonder because i
can't stop thinking about him
what do you think george left the
building and did right after that what
is the next step in his life
i think you know uh
george
left that it was the best thing that
could have happened to him you know
sometimes you think you want something
so bad and you george wasn't good at
what he did you know he wasn't a great
programmer but he had the best
intentions and the best personality the
person that you do want to go to work
with every day who cheers you you know
lifts you up and he's yes maybe a little
too energetic um and i love playing
george because he was so different than
guillermo you know and george was like
really kind of like bubbly and big and
like uh and energetic and i remember i
almost didn't do the role because i
couldn't they came to us twice and asked
if i could do the role and schedule wise
i couldn't because we're about to start
shooting uh season three of what we do
in the shadows and i just was so
heartbroken and they kept asking is he
available was available and i was like
oh my god can it work and they're like
no you're those are the days that are
blocked out like no and as luck would
have it this is how the universe works
also what's meant for you is meant for
you because at the last minute the 11th
hour
they called one more time like the third
time and they're like we know we've been
bugging you
is there any way and that same day we
had found out that the schedule for
shadows had shifted
and it had moved to a later date
i
they called
we said uh yes he's available they just
wanted me they wanted to show that i
could sing and they wanted me to send
tape even though i talked to the creator
uh austin after this he's i never asked
him to send i said give him the role and
apparently casting uh who did casper
glee and stuff was like can he send us a
tape just to make sure he's singing like
i never sung on television or film so i
didn't know if i could
but austin was like no i told him to
offer you the role and they came back
but we got a tape from him and he said
okay and they were like no i asked you
let's see it and then of course within
an hour of sitting in the tape or
something they were like can you be on a
plane tomorrow
and i was on a plane to vancouver uh
quarantine learning through mandy moore
choreographer uh to the gods i was just
like i can't believe this is happening
and they told me the song i was singing
the other song i was saying and i was
like what is happening and it was just
like
amazing and george i feel like was
supposed to come back actually spoiler
he was supposed to come back for zoe's
birthday episode uh and sing
kiss me because he comes back and this
is a story that i was told uh by the
creator he comes back and he's happy
he's like the head of his own company he
has a boyfriend he comes back and sings
kiss me because he comes back and
introduces the new boyfriend to the to
the whole gang and that was such a great
story like ark and i was like oh my gosh
and unfortunately this time around with
scheduling
that did not work so i couldn't come
back to vancouver i was already in
toronto shooting season three
so you heard it here first who knows
that
knowing that seriously makes me want to
cry tears of joy right now
makes me so incredibly happy for him and
that that production is just something
else i can't even imagine what it's like
especially when uh when i know you've
had some theater work in your past
getting the opportunity to bring that
skill set to a show like zoey's under
the guidance of a choreographer like
mandy moore especially this just to
specify the song i was referencing
before is stronger
hands down one of my favorite
performances of all of season two but i
really can't imagine what it must have
been like to work in that kind of
setting on a tv show for you
i mean it was a dream come true that was
and remember what the opening we started
with hello dolly but remember in the
actual season my dream came full circle
we sing hard knock life from annie and i
was literally like are you kidding me
like when you say heart like i was like
i i'm living my dream like literally
this is where i fell in love with acting
watching annie and i'm on set
reenacting my own version of an all-male
like cast because andy it's all girls
and now it's an all-male like we did a
gender bender with it and i was like i
manifested it i manifested this like
this is what i wanted to stop six and
now here we are seeing hard knock like
with all the boys after the baseball you
know uh jerseys and the bats and like
it's all cool and i was like this is
incredible so that's it
everyone who works in it super beautiful
and amazing and uh i wish i could have
come back for the for that uh episode
but uh but they're making a movie now so
you never know
i am so happy i cannot express how
excited i am about that
kicking it off with the very beginning
going back to the casting process here
already brought up uh allison and i was
wondering
what was it like going through the
allison jones casting process what is it
about that casting process that makes it
stand out from other ones that you've
been through before again what's meant
for you is done for you because i went
to a wine and cheese night
uh my friend mimi was having a couple of
friends over because she was in town to
bring her newborn baby to visit her
brother and her husband was with her and
mimi michaels we met in a set of a
commercial years ago and uh became
lifelong friends and so i was already in
my pajamas at home and she said i want
you to come you know see the baby and i
was like i'm wearing my pajamas and
when's the next time i'm going to see
her she lives in new york okay fine and
i put on some pants and i got dressed
and went to this wine cheese night
everyone there was his family except for
one person i never met before her friend
yvonne who she invited so we just talked
in the night and i don't think we talked
about the industry or hollywood or
anything we're just talking about
anything and everything and the next day
i get a text from unknown number and
it's yvonne she goes hey i hope you
don't mind i got your number for me i
think you're really funny and uh it was
great meeting you i was like you two i
was like stay in touch and she says and
i think you should audition for my
fiance's new show
and i said what and she's like yeah it's
like it's called what we do in the
shadows it was like the movie and she's
like well yeah it's a movie but now but
you need to hurry because everyone's
cast already except for this role and
they already cast kavon natasha mark and
matt and they couldn't find a guillermo
they had people on hold blah blah
and it was close to production like
correction was starting in a few weeks
and i said sure i'll buy it's like who's
the cast nurturer allison jones i'm like
yes i because i've never gotten in for
allison jones i mean allison jones like
you said is a legend and she kind of you
know knows what she wants so she kind of
has uh the ability to just go for what
she wants you know it's doesn't really
necessarily have cattle calls not that
i've been to you know what i mean and so
you get by invitation you get asked to
go allison jones and so i was like oh my
gosh if this is my way in to go see
allison jones i don't care about the
part i just want to go see allison jones
you know uh it's like yeah it's like
seeing the easter bunny at the mar or
santa claus you know you're like i don't
care what presents you just go meet them
and i call my agent and i was like hey
um so this girl i met at her party says
i should audition for this role who was
like oh her name is yvonne and it's her
fiance's new show what's her fiance's
name
yeah these are questions that i probably
should have asked before i called you so
i'm going to call her and ask her and i
sure enough i was like hey what's your
fiance's name it's a garrett bash i was
like gary bash and i go back and like
okay let me go check and then like
harvey that part is uh 20 years older
than you are they don't they wouldn't
see you for that part
and i was like but this stranger i just
met at a party says i'm perfect for it
why can't you guys listen to a stranger
like i did and they're like uh we'll
check it out if they can get you do you
think they can they're saying word in so
they did it was almost like a
like a
courtesy audition basically so i think
that she went and told gary i met this
guy i gave him an audition and he was
like okay i'll call allison allison gave
the goat to my reps to let me come in
for it the animal was 20 years older
than i am so yeah i read and i was like
oh my gosh it's 20 years older than i am
but this character is really cool and i
can play him how do i make myself look
older so i went to my
closet and got a rusty orange long
sleeve sweater under a long sleeve shirt
and a and a brown sweater vest and i
found these i never do this i never
dress for the part just maybe have an
element of the character feel to it
but for this i wanted to make an
impression on allison and i just want
even if it was a bad one i guess because
i was like this could go terribly wrong
so then i found these harry potter
glasses and i popped out the lenses
these circle glasses and then i parted
my hair in the middle i was like oh man
this is going to age me out like so it's
so gross i'm gonna curl it like that
it's gonna be so yeah i know who would
look like this on television
and then i went into the office and i
was like and there was no one there it
was like courtesy audition it was just
me and no one else and i was like i'm
here to see allison like she's not here
and i was like but but i have an
appointment well we'll put you on tape
she's auditioning guillermos i think
like in london or something and i was
like
no i'm supposed to meet alison jones uh
but ben was there and who's lovely and
put the microphone on my you know caller
and i remember just auditioning and
after i was done with the audition
i just didn't remember anything and i
looked up and i was like and ben looked
at me goes
you're done and i go oh thank you and i
walk out the door and he goes harley
wait and i go i think he's gonna be like
you're the one kid you're going to
hollywood and then he goes the
microphone
and he checks
i walked away with the microphone and
then i stepped out of the office and it
was just like this surreal moment of
like i i knew i i
i did the character i just don't
remember what i did and then i walked
out and i was like well at least i fell
into guillermo that's what i felt
guillermo was getting didn't have a last
name at that moment like it was just
like the description and then i walked
out and i talked to my agent he was like
how'd you do it i don't know i really
don't know but i didn't get it to meet
allison so we'll see
two hours later they called and said
that they had all voted unanimously to
test me with kvon they had fx uh you
know paul stephanie taika ytt germain
everyone for the first time because they
had people on hold for the role but they
were 60 40 votes or you know 70 30 like
they weren't like you know on the same
page and for the first time they
unanimously voted to test me and i was
going to be the wild card because i
wasn't old enough for guillermo so i was
like hey i'll be the one i made a living
out of being a wild card so i'll go for
the wild card so then a couple like days
go by and then eventually it's tomorrow
the king weekend i haven't heard back
and i'm like they didn't they didn't
they're not going to test me they're
like at this point they start production
like next week it was already sunday and
then they started production that we i
knew they started production that like
wednesday or something and i was like i
didn't hear back and then i was like
it's done and then the phone kept
ringing from a 16 digit number and i
wouldn't pick it up and also my sister
and then she finally said will you pick
up the phone and i was like okay and i
was hello it's like hey is this javi and
i was like uh yes hey it's taikan
germain
oh yes yes i'm testing for you it's like
no you're not testing for us and i was
like oh okay thank you so much for
considering me then no you're the guy
you and i was like what what he said
you're you're the guy we'll see you on
set and i was like
i booked it without testing they said
why are we testing this guy we all voted
for him he it's like i've never had a
chemistry with kayvon
i got the part on the sunday i had to
call my agents and tell them that i got
the part on sunday they were like harvey
no you're testing what are you talking
about i got the part
they probably thought i was insane you
know like calling them on a weekend and
then they're like no we'll check it out
by monday it was marathon weekend uh and
they found out like yeah you did book it
i had a fitting on tuesday and i was on
set on wednesday
what a ride yeah
just to backtrack a little because i had
read that the role was originally meant
for someone much older and it was making
me wonder and i don't know if you know
the answer to this or if you remember
what those sides were but i was curious
like
how would that have changed the
character and his relationship with the
vampires if he had been older because
when i think about that role it is so
specific to you and it's so specific to
the fact that you know guillermo still
does have that like bubbly youthful
enthusiasm but we're at a point where
we're seeing that kind of disappear into
you know the next phase of a career and
kind of aging and losing that so i can't
even imagine what someone older would
have done with a role like that
i think the original version they had
for guillermo was someone that was older
and if you look around the story lines
the all the familiars around us are
pretty much they're older remember
guillermo roses they're all i can
remember benji like who comes back and
he's still not a vampire that was the
idea that the familiar should be aging
and never anywhere near becoming a
vampire so that was the idea originally
i think with guillermo but i when i came
along they're like well why don't we
make him younger like and he starts
realizing that wait a minute remember
that first season when he goes to the
familiar's room and there's people
telling stories around the table like
i've been familiar for 70 years he
promised me to make me one before i hit
80. and
guillermo realizes they're not going to
make him they're not making him a
vampire he's a familiar forever and he
started realizing is this a mirror is
this my life like this is what's going
to happen to me you know so it actually
worked um i think to everyone's
advantage that we made guillermo you
know younger than he originally was
because otherwise you're right how would
he end up being a slayer you know he was
20 years older and like not going
through that journey of like
self-discovery or that trajectory with a
storyline would make sense and to the
point where he didn't have last name
like i remember going to jermaine and
saying can i give him the last name
because when i do the interviews you
know we do the confessional interviews
um you know i want to slate my name like
they would ask on a real documentary you
know or something and so what do you
want to call him and i was like i don't
know guillermo
de la cruz and mind you i didn't know
anything of the story yet i didn't even
know where story arc was going i knew he
wasn't familiar and that's all i knew
and he goes yeah
yeah and so what does that mean and he's
like it means of the cross and he said
that's perfect and i did not know why
but i was like there you go okay great i
just thought i picked a cool name i had
no idea that it was perfect it was
kismet to name this character guillermo
de la cruz who ends up being the
descendant of van helsing
see what i mean it all happens the way
it's supposed to
yeah and so i i'm curious
about
this like two day journey from audition
to set basically and
that gives you very little time to prep
your character work like in the more
traditional sense but also from what i
understand and have read
you often don't know where you're going
very much in advance with this series so
did that turn out to be like a helpful
initial way to have approached the
character to just have to get on set and
go
well it did and it didn't
uh because um
since he's the only human in the show uh
you know humans are driven by needs and
wants and aspiration and uh and all of
those things that make us human the
vampires in the first season are just
after lust you know feeding and that's
pretty easy because that's been their
regular day-to-day for hundreds of years
when you don't have a time frame of like
times running out you stop thinking
about like goals and aspiration and for
the animal the clock is ticking he's
been a familiar for 10 years and he gets
rewarded and he thinks it's only been
two years and his
his mind is like ten is that how long
wow two years wow you know it's like put
it in your depressing room and i started
realizing he doesn't have the same
thought process that guillermo does as a
human it's like the clock is ticking and
i give this backstory to guillermo that
he wants to be a vampire because
he hits aspirational living like he
wants to be he wants to be young forever
he wants to be
beautiful he wants to be you know
glamorous he wants to be able to fly he
wants to be able he wants all these
things that make being a vampire so cool
at the age though that he could still
enjoy it you know because the clock's
ticking you're gonna be stuck in that
age for eternity and so if you don't do
it when you're young it's going to be
like that was your window you know and
it was just like do you want to be a
vampire at 80 you know it's like always
feeling 80 every day and so uh that's
the backstory i gave to your mom but it
made it really difficult the first
season because they wouldn't give us the
scripts ahead of time which i i was like
i would like to we also cross shoot
which means that in one episode or one
day of shooting we might shoot episode
102 in the morning and by the afternoon
at lunch we're at 106 and then in the
evening we're back to 104
and so
it just it jumps timelines and we don't
have the episodes so they give us
sometimes just like the sides of
episodes and so then we get to like a
scene and we're like guillermo gets in
his car when did he get a car oh in the
early episode what happens then we can't
tell you not yet and it's like well
shouldn't i what i was like i need to
know to know what motivates me to get
into the just we'll tell you this
you're terrified
you just did something
you're dead uh you are dead okay action
you know and it's just like wait
what why am i dead why am i scared and
so when you look at guillermo the first
season he looks terrified half the time
it's just not only because he's running
with the vampires who can demote him
another year of being a familiar just
like that
but he's i i feel like he was terrified
he didn't know what the next thing is
which makes the documentary look real
you know it makes to look like this
character in front of the camera is
terrified of the secrets being leaked
out by his housemates in front of a
camera that can incriminate the only
human
in the house they're vampires if the
truth got out they can fly away
transylvania they can fly away another i
can't i have all this weight on my
shoulders if this ever leaked out you
know and so there was a lot of pressure
on weight on the human and also it also
helped me though develop this character
too
we've all been guillermo you know we've
all been in his shoes we've opened a job
that we overlooked for a promotion or in
love with someone from afar or you know
but i feel that's why everyone is drawn
to that storyline because we can all
relate to the human storyline
you've spoken a lot about you know
things happening like in a way that they
were meant to be so it was making me
wonder do you have your own interview
with a vampire like did you have a
vampire movie you watched growing up
that now it kind of comes full circle
and you are in a vampire show
well funny enough that is the movie
interview vampire is
vampire so see that's what i'm saying i
just love i mean i fell in love also
with like christians acting as a child
actor i was like oh my god you know
like i can do it like that was
inspirational i was like because i
always wanted to act when i was a kid so
when i saw other connectors on screen it
was aspirational i was like yes you
could do it you know and so i kept
training and training and and working
out my craft because it looks like some
some kids can do it they're on screen
they can do it so and it was my favorite
and it was um something about it that
was so like uh
i don't know alluring and like
uh provocative and and sexual you know
something about it was like taboo like
it was like both the male characters and
i was like why are they so close and why
aren't like really good friends or
something you know but like it was
something about just the that that time
in new orleans and that the
the details of the set like it was just
all of it really kind of grabbed my eye
and and remains like my favorite vampire
movie pretty much you mentioned the the
cross-shooting approach and a specific
question i wanted to ask about season
three because you guys shot this now
among more coveted precautions did that
change that format of filming at all
this season i don't think so i think
that we obviously took every precaution
to do this safely um and and i actually
felt safest on set you know because
you're tested every day and whatnot um
then i did go into the grocery store you
know like i would try to go to the
grocery store in toronto because you
don't know you know and you do know when
you walk to set that everyone there has
been you know checked off the list
and so it didn't really change the
storyline we weren't able to do massive
like group scenes like they remember the
orgy episode we had so many background
which
that episode is so great and brilliant
that we weren't able to do as many
um but we were able to do you know group
scenes and whatnot uh but it wouldn't be
able to do as many because for
everyone's safety reasons obviously but
it doesn't hinder the show at all i
think if anything it's just like nothing
has happened when you watch the show
i think it's gonna be you know very
cohesive it's gonna feel like back like
the old day like nothing like in that
world that never took place you know and
in that world uh it's just where you
left off and continue the story which is
i think the best because uh what we do
here is we make an escape for people
right so for like 30 minutes you laugh
your ass off and that's what you can do
i always say i'm not a first responder
i'm not a doctor but what i can
contribute is entertainment and through
entertainment if i can make you smile
for 30 minutes then that's what i
contribute and that's what i can look
back and be like i did my part
to help out during this time as much as
i could
that you did and it is very appreciated
with the uh the documentary shooting
style like day one when you first
stepped on set was there anything about
that different kind of filming style
that really threw you or actually maybe
a better phrasing of that is what would
you say to an actor who was about to
film a show in that style what one piece
of advice did you wish you had day one
that would help them out
um be aware that the camera is a
character
that you know for so long when you're
doing tv and film you don't look at the
camera because you don't that you don't
acknowledge it you're not breaking the
fourth wall and in a show like this
the camera is a character the crew is a
character uh you so if you notice
when guillermo looks to the camera it's
because it's basically saying without
words but we're all thinking because the
only humans in that room
are the camera crew and guillermo so
sometimes when they do something to
someone or say something incriminating
it's like did you get that like if it's
like looking at a human
who you can have an instant rapport with
so if you are doing something like this
and you're all human
then remember that the camera itself is
a character there's a person there uh
that you can bounce off you know uh
because you know otherwise when you do a
movie uh that's not this tower tv show
you don't donate onto the camera it's
not there right it's just we captured it
we're a fly on the wall but in this
moment it's i feel like it's a character
and that's why it plays off like you you
give a wing to the camera or you give a
look or whatever because they are there
in the journey in the moment in the room
with you which is all of you
so you wanted to give your character
last name before you even knew he had
one and just it sounds to me like in
general you like to put that that time
and care into backstory work to really
fill out the role when you get to set so
with that in mind with the carrot with
the camera being a character just for
you guys while you're on set performing
with them do you have to know everybody
but like do you give them backstories
and names so it feels real on that level
uh yeah i mean like we don't necessarily
use the names of the actual crew because
we can make as an improvise we can make
the crew be whoever whatever name we
give them in this last season i did do a
take where uh i did
tell uh our director at that point was
jana and i i literally
i'm doing this and i want to give too
much but i'm saying something to the
camera and then realize i said it and
then i look over and then i
with still being connected to the camera
documentary crew and i look over and i
say yana can you can you just cut that
out you know or something like that
where like you said something that you
regret and that would be like an initial
reaction of the year something that was
incriminating like oh no can you edit
that and edit you know like the idea
that you're talking to the character i
don't know if we'll use it i don't know
if that but that was one of the takes
that we did um in one scene but um i
don't know because i haven't seen the
episode yet but uh if we did use it it
would be very much very on brand it
would be very you know easy to use i
love the idea of your actual directors
being part of this this world that you
built too there's like a really cool
meta touch about it
she responded with her voice and she was
like yeah guillermo like she said use
guillermo she didn't use harvey
obviously but she was in character two
responding to guillermo with the
questions uh because you know when you
do this documentary or like you know
documentaries or reality shows you
usually go to the producer or you don't
hear the producer the second before
asking the you know uh the inter the
person being interviewed like so what is
it like growing up here and that person
has to answer with like growing up here
is like you know but uh usually you
don't hear the voice but sometimes you
might you might hear a voice of a
producer of the documentary or you know
you never know so those that world uh
does exist but we could use them in the
show
you talked about how
you know for a while you don't know
exactly where your character is going to
go and you have to play the scene as
you're directed to play it in the moment
but i wonder is there
do you have like a true north for
guillermo or or something that you hold
on to to keep the
true to the character even if you don't
know where the story is going to take
him
yeah i think for the first season not
knowing a lot about the character ahead
of time because basically we built him
right they they thought they wanted this
character to be 20 years older and that
didn't pan out so we kind of started
from scratch they kind of had an idea of
what they wanted and i talked to the
creators about this and you know i think
it was a collaboration you know of what
i brought to the table for him and what
they saw and they said you know what now
that we know you know that the year we
do this and that like uh why don't we do
this you know when we start like
building that
i think that where i thought his story
arc would go in the first season didn't
pan out because i didn't know about the
vent housing which was way cooler than i
thought and then once you jump on that
wagon there's a whole other wagon being
built you know so you can never like
really as the artist unless you're the
one who's also writing the script you
don't really get to
make the destination for guillermo you
know or your character and so but i like
the surprises i like that he's amazing
at you know combat i like that all these
like you know stunned things he gets to
do um but at the end of the day i do
know why i want one thing for guillermo
and that's for him to be happy
like i want everyone to be happy because
i think uh he fell into this world
because he didn't have a happy you know
upbringing not necessarily at home i
think he has a wonderful lovely mother
at home i think that he was uh my
backstory for him is that he was
potentially not popular and he was
bullied and so he he kind of withdrew
himself into the world of movies and in
the world of movies he fell in love with
this potential world and searched if
that was actually a thing and he found
it he did his research and found out
that vampires are real and he committed
himself to be familiar to one of them in
return for eternal life
in the pool world of being a vampire and
being you know
just beautiful and powerful and no one's
going to mess with him when he's a
vampire that's his idea and
unfortunately time's running out and
it's like when are you going to make me
but then you start realizing that for so
long you have a goal in mind that you
think this is what your destiny should
be your hair has to be so perfectly
because this is this is how you tie up
your you know your sweater vest has to
be because you think this is what you
should be and at the end of the day the
universe is like look over here look
over here and it's like what look over
here and it's like take this right over
here for a second and then you start
checking out different opportunity and
then you start realizing you're really
good and you're real natural at what's
already in you
what we do in the shadows and zoe i hear
it in both of them
yeah
so what about the
writing process from you know season one
when you're essentially starting over
from scratch with this character to now
is there any uh you know added element
of the collaboration now that you're
really knee-deep in this series and this
role is so purely you are you able to
collaborate with the writing team in a
different way kind of adding another
level to that process now
uh i am i'm able to contribute a little
bit yes again i'm not by any means a
writer on the show who knows maybe in
the future i'll write an episode or
i don't know you know anything's
possible but i do collaborate with
scenes that are important uh to do with
this culture like uh there was a scene
where we meet his mom and stephanie and
paul came to me and said okay let's work
on this together and i went up to the
offices and we just punched out the
scene basically on how would be what
would that environment look like what
kind of language would be used with them
you know there was a conversation of
like well when they speak in spanish
shouldn't we put subtitles and the
response of paul which was brilliant was
like no people should learn spanish and
so
so his idea was like if there's
something in spanish um and it wasn't
like we're giving paragraphs in spanish
it was like one or two sentences which
were enough to be like what does that
mean and then you kind of put it
together by just seeing the you know um
communication with them and the way
they're reacting to each other you can
you know when you watch a porn film and
you don't look at the subtitles
sometimes just the acting is good enough
to just tell you what's going on in this
scene you know but it's there to read or
just double check you know it's just
like oh yeah yeah that's what i would i
thought they were fighting and i got it
yeah
whatever it is and so for the that's
very important to me that
that life was presented uh being a
mexican household and being with his mom
and the way that she's like uh you know
uh working on the freezer and like it's
starting to like break down and she's
making noise while the interviews are
because i no longer live in the house
and i have to turn around and tell amma
you know in the way of saying amma um
it's a short endearing version of mother
and that you wouldn't know that unless
you do it yourself and like i got so
many people
who just sent me messages through social
media and they're like oh my god when
you said amman i felt like i was in my
living room with my mom
i felt like so like i felt seen i felt
so seen and the bunuelos in the
background that was another one where it
was important to have authentic things
in the household and we have an amazing
team that does like stat decoration and
props uh then the prop team
looked at bunuelos but there's different
types of vanillas there's like you know
salvadoran and colombian bunnies and
they had these bunnies ship that weren't
mexican when yellows they were different
kind of vanillas or these balls of dough
which are delicious uh but they're not
mexican minerals and so it's like mixing
with yellows are flat and they're with
sugar and cinnamon and they're lightly
fried and so she started to panic the
you know the prop master was like oh no
oh no no i have this [ __ ] i'm so sorry
i'm so sorry and they're like [ __ ] what
do we do and i was like it's okay go get
me a packet of flour tortillas sugar
cinnamon and canola oil and i'll make
them and we made them up into the last
moment before we started shooting i was
making the willows in the background
putting them in a pile next to him in
the background as they said actually
like right before they said action just
so we had that authentic feeling so i
could never live with myself if we
didn't have the right willows behind me
because then we wouldn't be true to this
character
obviously kind of the running bit is of
course that guillermo wants to be a
vampire but he's coming up to the
realization that that's a false promise
however as a performer i feel like i
probably couldn't resist and i wonder if
you have been able to resist like
imagining how you would want to play
guillermo if he was a vampire you know
what i thought about it and it changes
all the time because i feel um when i
think of it i think of it through
like guillermo's lens and it and his
lens keeps changing uh filters
and so when i think about what he
thought about in the first season it was
one way and it was very close to
very close to an antonio banderas an
interview with a vampire
because that's his his aspiration and
then as the seasons went on i started
shifting a little bit into just more of
a
cool glamorous
like looking with like fitted like
outfits that are
cool and almost futuristic looking and
that last time i checked for guillermo
it's gonna be like this badass vampire
like no frills like uh
boots like it's just like the whole
ensemble changes in my mind for him
every time we present a different
element or ingredient into the mix so i
don't know what i think about him today
and the overall package will be what
it's different tomorrow because also
he's evolving with every season and so
i'm i'll be i'll be happy to see if that
happens first of all and when it happens
and
and then if it does happen how that
looks but already with guillermo as um
kind of a you know bodyguard he's
feeling really confident so if you
notice i work closely with the costume
designer who's amazing and and just the
detail of like he's more he's nice lumpy
like his sweaters aren't like just like
you know he's more fitted he's feeling
more pride he like doesn't feel too
ashamed of showing a little bit of more
like armed like he's always covered up
you know guillermo's always covered up
completely his sweaters turtle necks are
you know or buttoned up he doesn't wear
turnips but button up you know and
everything in long like now he's not so
so afraid
of being himself and that means being
comfortable in your body and that means
it's okay to feel comfortable if an
outfit is fitted and you show your
curves that's okay that's your body and
be proud of it so i'm really glad that
in this next season you get to see a
little bit of more sassy guillermo and a
little more stylish and a little like
pop color and like so i really like i
enjoyed the journey that he's going with
now with his outfit
to add another layer to hayley's
question so you kind of just broke down
how he would picture himself if he were
a vampire but what about
what about
what he would think about what to do
with those powers and also his
relationship with his familiar given
everything that he's been through how
has that goal changed in terms of how he
would carry himself in that role should
that ever happen
uh
yeah
that's uh that's kind of a crossroads
you know
um i feel that it it would change
dramatically if it went one way or the
other um and i and i kind of like that
i'm living with him in a in a little
space right now where he knows he's
incentive than housing and it's in him
but he hasn't let go of the dream he
doesn't let go of the dream completely
and so that makes for a nice like uh
hybrid
of a dream and so maybe now the
potential of these worlds intertwining
is starting to form and the idea that it
could be molding and
awaken something in him that maybe he
didn't even think before and then before
you know it is completely
pulled
i think that one of the most fascinating
things about guillermo is his like his
stick-to-it-ness like and he he is so
committed to this dream and this
lifestyle and
we have seen him put up with so much we
have seen him do all kinds of shady
things uh for this lifestyle
yeah like you said he's putting himself
in the danger of letting it be on camera
do you think this character has a
breaking point does that exist for you
absolutely
apps frequently and you see it this
season
you see it you see a breaking point
uh you will see a breaking point for
guillermo this season and
it is going to be
intense
i feel like that essentially answered my
my other broad tease question is there
is there anything else you want to tell
our viewers about what to expect in
season three about i mean maybe just
specifically guillermo but also beyond
look out for
um
what those uh ingredients are you know
we've already seen it been sprinkled for
the last two seasons and he's only been
familiar for uh 10 years 11 years now
uh and i think everyone has a breaking
point like you said and
and it's justified i mean i'll say that
a breaking point sometimes you know
people like well keep your cool it's
like no one is cooler
in that way than guillermo you know no
one has kept it together and no one's
kept the lid on you know on things
longer than he has so when it does
happen
it's gonna feel like uh
yes like do you know and so
there is that moment and i can't wait
for everyone to see it because
i i couldn't wait to film it because you
as a performer like come on how much can
this character take you know this is
like punches and punches and punches of
like you know uh belittling and
mistreatment and then when you finally
like you know
you kind of like you know cheer for
someone it feels good and so i hope i
hope that people feel good with uh with
what he does and how he does it
i cannot wait to hit that point
all right so we always end witching hour
with the same two questions haley i will
give you the honors this time do you
want to pick one of the two first
sure my my personal favorite and the
most important question of all time do
you have any pets
i don't have any pets but my sister has
two dogs that i am basically an uncle to
because i travel a lot for work and so i
don't have any pets i did when i was
little i had several dogs i had chico
which is a pomeranian and then i had
pirata which was a dalmatian and he had
a patch so we called him pirate pirata
uh so i had two dogs growing up uh and
uh but i don't have any pets
unfortunately
dog uncle grounds it very much does
all right so the other one that we
always like to end on is
is there anything within
genre that you want to recommend to our
viewers whether it's a book you read a
show you watched a movie a game you name
it something that is in genre or you
know horror adjacent that somebody out
there might like
hmm
i mean i do like like um documentaries
that are
thrillers or
who done it i don't know if that goes
hand in hand with like horror but it is
horrifying to me to like solve
a murder mystery or a missing person uh
that one of the characters in our show
you know one of the victims could have
easily had a spin-off of uh you know
some podcast that tries to figure out
what happened to them you know
so i would recommend um you know
documentaries like that i my sister and
i we like watching those um
i've been watching
uh
or listening to
a crime junkie uh the podcast where they
try to like you know bring light into
like missing uh
old stories of like murder or missing
people or whatnot and i always think
what is like
i mean in a different world someone did
a podcast of like a character that went
missing in staten island that happened
to go to the house and was a victim of
the vampires and someone's out there
looking for them and that like you know
so i thought about that i was like
that's connected right like that could
easily be a storyline
i would listen to that in a heartbeat
yeah
all right harvey we gotta let you go
huge congratulations on everything
you've accomplished on what we do in the
shadows thus far and i think i could
speak for both of us and probably our
audience as well when i say i cannot
wait to see what season three has to
offer i am so pumped
110
thank you this has been fun
big thanks again to harvey for dropping
by to chat with us and thanks to fx is
what we do in the shadows for bringing
you this episode be sure to catch harvey
and the rest of the shadows cast
including special guest star kristen
shaw when the all-new season of what we
do in the shadows premieres thursday
september 2nd on fx streaming next day
on fx on hulu that's it for this week
you have officially survived the
witching hour